A large double-engined aircraft
just flew into the World Trade Center.
This idea of ramming
an aircraft into a building,
it wasn’t on
our radar screen.
I was now
the national security adviser
on a day
of the worst attack
on American territory
since the war of 1812.
American 11 757
possible hijack.
Stop all departures.
In a crisis like this
it’s really all-consuming.
There is a lot that you don’t know,
and there’s a lot that
you think you know
that is wrong.
Vice President Cheney
then turned to me and said,
The president has authorized
a shoot-down of an aircraft.”
It was hijacked and
represented a true threat.
The president
didn’t have time<
to go through<
the pros and cons.
Every plane that
was in the air
was a potential missile.
When 93 went down,
there was a<
terrible moment where
we all thought that<
perhaps we’d shot it down.